ahora vamos a ver un ejemplo un poco más
complicado entre dos opciones de pago
los dos van a ser muy buenas porque en
las dos te van a dar dinero pero bueno a
ver opción 1
el día de hoy
te voy a dar 100 pesos
a 100 pesos
y bueno voy a remarcar los pagos con
color magenta
entonces a ver aquí en la opción 1 el
día de hoy te pago 100 pesos
y veamos la opción 2
opción 2
y bueno esta opción se trata de que no
en un año sino en dos años te pague yo
un poco de dinero habrá hecho hasta el
año 1 y ahora el año 2
bueno de hecho te voy a dar tres
opciones
y lo cual va a hacer que todo quede muy
claro
pero bueno entonces tenemos que mover la
opción 2 un poco a la izquierda
entonces bueno aquí está la opción 2
son 2
estoy dispuesta a pagar te digamos no sé
110 pesos dentro de dos años no en un
año si no entro dentro de dos años
610 pesos y también lo voy a remarcar
con color más gente diciendo que esto es
un pago ya en el año 2
ahora la opción 3 va a ser fácilmente
opción 3 va a ser bueno le estoy
poniendo un color distinto
bueno la opción 3 en la opción 3 te voy
a pagar
como ven lo estoy improvisando aquí pero
bueno te va a pagar 20 pesos el día de
hoy
y después de un año te voy a pagar 50
pesos
en un año
entonces son 70 pesos entonces bueno
estaba cerca
y dentro de dos años te va a pagar 35
pesos
ok 35 pesos
entonces todos estos son pagos ok y los
estoy circulando porque los quiero
diferenciar del valor actual que ahorita
vamos a ponerle su valor actual y para
hacer las cosas más simples supongamos
que yo soy la persona más confiable del
mundo que si el mundo existe si el sol
no se vuelve una estrella supernova y
explota yo te voy a pagar estas
cantidades en estos tiempos entonces soy
tan libre de riesgo como el gobierno
alguien hizo un comentario en el vídeo
anterior preguntando si el gobierno
realmente era tan seguro y pues este es
un punto muy importante si el gobierno
toma prestados 100 pesos y promete
regresar los en un año el gobierno
definitivamente va a regresar los 100
pesos el único problema es cuánto van a
valer esos 100 pesos dentro de un año
porque el gobierno de inflar la moneda
muchísimo pero bueno no me voy a meter
en eso ahorita vamos a regresar al valor
actual de hecho algunos gobiernos se han
dejado de pagar sus deudas pero países
como eeuu no lo han hecho nunca han
inflado muchísimo su moneda que es una
forma de darle la vuelta a dejar de
pagar sus deudas pero nunca ha dicho así
tal cual no te voy a pagar si hiciera
eso todo el sistema financiero se cae al
piso y todos viviríamos de sembrar la
tierra otra vez bueno de regreso al
ejercicio entonces bueno vamos a
comparar la opción 1 con la opción 2 y
bueno vamos a decir otra vez que podemos
prestarle nuestro dinero al gobierno sin
riesgo
y vamos a escribirlo por acá tasa sin
riesgo y vamos a decir que es de un 5% y
bueno para que sean las cosas simples
vamos a suponer que es la misma tasa sin
importar si le prestas al gobierno tu
dinero donde un año dos años o tres años
en el siguiente vídeo vamos a
complicarlo un poco más entonces bueno
si tengo 100 pesos el día de hoy cuánto
valdrá dentro de un año pues ya sabemos
cómo calcularlo no tenemos que
multiplicarlo por 1.05 y eso es
105 pesos
y después si se lo prestas al gobierno a
otro año y te paga otro 5% entonces
tenemos que multiplicar 105 por 1.05
y cuántos eso pues tenemos 105 x 1.05 y
nos da 110 puntos 25
entonces aquí escribamos la
110 punto 25 pesos entonces ese es el
valor de nuestros 100 pesos dentro de 2
años y aquí directamente podemos ya ver
qué nos conviene tomar el dinero ahorita
y prestárselo al gobierno durante dos
años porque nos va a dar punto 25 pesos
más mientras que yo solo estoy dispuesto
a darte 110 pesos dentro de dos años
bueno pero o sea de lo que queremos
hablar del título de este vídeo es el
valor actual entonces bueno vamos a
convertirlo todo en términos de el día
de hoy cuánto valen esos diez pesos 110
pesos el día de hoy
entonces 110 pesos dentro de dos años
cuánto vale dentro de un año pues
tenemos que tomar los 110 pesos y
dividirlos entre 1.051 simplemente
estamos haciendo el procedimiento
inverso y obtenemos un número aquí que
podemos denotar por esta cosa y después
para obtener el valor actual tenemos que
dividir este número entre 1.05 otra vez
si fuera a dividir otra vez entre 1.05
obtendría
110 / 1.05 al cuadrado y esto que es
igual
estoy escribiendo lo de esta forma para
que te acostumbres a esta anotación
porque así es como lo vamos a escribir
mucho tiempo osea dividiendo entre 1 más
la tasa de descuento a la potencia de la
cantidad de años y es muy importante
esta anotación y poder usarla
entonces bueno sacamos la calculadora
para ver cuánto es son 110 pesos entre
1.05 al cuadrado la cantidad de años y
eso es igual a 99 puntos 77 pesos vamos
a cambiarlo de color 99 puntos 77 pesos
entonces otra vez hemos verificado que
el valor actual
bueno utilizando el valor actual de 110
pesos el día de hoy asumiendo una tasa
de descuento del 5% ahora aquí este es
justo el lugar más jugoso de finanzas lo
puedes cambiar algunas cositas hacer
cualquier suposición pero bueno ahorita
para que sea simple estamos suponiendo
que es una tasa de descuento constante y
sin riesgo entonces el valor actual de
110 dentro de dos años es 99 puntos 77
pesos y pues yo prefiero tener 100 pesos
hoy que 99 puntos 77
a la opción 3 es muy interesante como
vemos esto lo que hacemos es sacamos el
valor actual de cada uno de estos pagos
esto es bueno el valor actual de 20
pesos ahorita el son 20 pesos y bueno el
valor actual de 50 pesos dentro de un
año
es más
50 / 1.05 ese es el valor actual de 50
pesos dentro de un año y ahora quiero el
valor actual de los 35 pesos lo cual es
más 35 pesos dividido entre son 2 años
entonces tenemos que dividir entre 1.05
al cuadrado
de la misma forma en que lo hicimos en
la opción 2 ok entonces tengo que sumar
todos esos valores actuales
saco mi calculadora virtual
entonces el valor actual de los 20 pesos
son 20 pesos
más los 50 pesos en valor actual que es
50 / 1.05 más el valor actual de los 35
pesos que es 35 entre son dos años
porque entonces tenemos que elevar el
1.0 5 al cuadrado
entonces dividimos entre 1.05 al
cuadrado
y listo eso es igual a vamos a redondear
lo entonces nos quedan 99 punto 37 pesos
99 pesos con 37 centavos ahora si
podemos hacer una muy buena comparación
entre las tres opciones esto podría
haber sido muy confuso antes sabes
tienes a esta persona que quiere hacer
un contrato contigo que tiene la forma
de un plan de retiro una agencia de
seguros y te dice oye tú págame esto en
los años
abc y yo te pago esto en los años de ibc
y como comparas estas opciones pues esta
es la forma sacas el valor actual de
todos los pagos y ves cuánto vale eso
para ti hoy y hicimos eso y encontramos
que la opción 1 era la mejor pero
depende de cómo salgan las cuentas si
bajó la tasa de descuento probablemente
cambiaría el resultado tal vez haga eso
en el siguiente vídeo sólo para
enseñarte lo importante que es la tasa
de descuento nos vemos